candid truth as some of you guys might
know I've stated it before I have a
degree related to
computers um specifically that was cyber
security um God had other plans for my
life
obviously but I'm going to share with
you a paper I wrote on a book that I had
to read in that class a specific class
was one of the first classes I had to
take and it was called Cyber Law policy
and enforcement
now keep in mind that this was coming
from a professor that was not a
Christian he had a past in the hacking
world and we had been told as students
that we had several undisclosed CIA FBI
agents in the class so this had quite a
few of government um agents or officials
in it that were taking his class for a
refresher or for some reason
um when our graduating class graduated
they were hiring directly from our class
for opening positions within those
agencies and the interesting part was
that this whole book here we are reading
it here we are hearing about a cult
groups and satanists and Witchcraft and
all this stuff and the fact that they're
using music in the media and nobody
nobody is denying it it is a fact this
became very important to me and and if
you're interested in reading it is
actually a really great read mainly
because as a Christian it brought up a
lot of connections with the occult and
satanic involvement in cyber crime and
in the cyber space of the internet and
we're going to dive into that a little
bit with some of what I said this will
be very very
short but I said in my paper a
particular interest is the book's
admittance of the use of speech utilized
by groups or branches of
neo-nazism white supremacy or extremist
Christians later mentioning satanic
groups those who believe they are
superior Supreme and elitists in general
seem to use hate
speech there is a reason for this as
these groups are undeniably rooted in
such mentalities none is better than the
other each is unique in having different
anisms talents and skills different but
equal however when it comes to these
groups they are all different flavors of
these kinds of things I'm just adding
that right now but back to what I said
rather insightful evidence of this is
the statement of former klex Clan Grand
Dragon Dawn black as he created a
prominent hate speech website promoting
white supremacy using hate speech on
their websites and social media
platforms for recruiting and propagation
of their ideas some groups use memes
humor or even hateful language and music
of course we see that all the time
there's all kinds of sad hateful speech
and making fun of another and all kinds
of things but mainly in music you can
see that a lot in music but specifically
with the klex plan it is a this music
This Hate language type music they offer
is a free gift of heavy metal to spread
the anger and violence ideologies which
benefit their
agenda the media is packed with
subliminal messaging to convince those
who are open to such ideas and
bitterness and hate towards control
rules government and so on to become
likeminded in their cause interestingly
the Bible says that we are all vessels
either for Jesus Christ or Satan
according to how we Act and the
decisions we make daily every day and
every moment is a choice for one or the
other Satan is called the accuser not
unlike hate speech it originated with
him when we give into all these things
especially putting each other down like
this and using music to influence one
another is not godly but it's
interesting coming straight from the
words
of this book in which they
quoted this klex clanned Grand
Dragon that they use this music not
unlike other groups a lot of other
groups do the same thing with music to
do so and they might mention
others so be careful and just know that
what you are putting in to your mind
comes out and actually is kind of like a
control mechanism a scop mission for
them to get into your mind and plant
seeds to control you all right bye guys
[Music]
[Applause]